[Music]
just over 30 miles away from the
slovenian capital
this alpine lake looks like it belongs
on the cover of a storybook
[Music]
with a fairy tale cliffside castle an
emerald green freshwater lake and views
of some of the highest peaks of the
julian alps
lake bled and its island church make a
postcard perfect scene
[Applause]
to visit the assumption of mary church
you must catch a ride on a wooden boat
known as a plenta
plentas have been taking visitors to the
island in the middle of the lake for
centuries
[Applause]
once reaching the island it's a 99 stone
step climb to reach the entrance to the
church
it is said that if a groom could carry
his bride up these steps and ring the
wishing belt at the top
the marriage would be a happy one
[Music]
the church is most famous for this bow
which was made in the early 16th century
and is said to be a gift from the pope
has it this was the church's second bell
the first was bought for the church by
an inconsolable widow in honor of her
late husband who was murdered and then
thrown into the lake
when boatman brought it across to the
church an unexpected storm head and the
bell sunk to the bottom
it is said if you listen closely in the
dead of night you can hear the sunken
bell ringing from the depths of this
picturesque lake
[Music]
a two-hour boat ride off the coast of
colombia is an island
the most densely populated island on
earth
[Music]
santa cruz del eslate consists of more
than 1 200 people living on land the
size of two soccer fields making it four
times as dense as manhattan
on the island is a school that runs up
to the 10th grade two shops and one
restaurant
there is no steady supply of water and a
soul generator that only runs for five
hours per day
there are no police but there isn't much
need for them as everyone on the island
knows each other
150 years ago the island was primarily
uninhabited and was sometimes used by
local fishermen as a place to rest and
take shelter during storms
gradually some fishermen came to build
their homes here these were the
grandparents and great grandparents of
the current generation of residents
despite the close living quarters
inhabitants on the island say they
wouldn't give up their peaceful
existence for anything not even a little
more room
[Music]
[Music]
what do you say to people who just say
this is not a normal way of living
thank you very much
[Music]
i'm catherine and this is my husband
wayne
i'm wayne and welcome to freedom coat
[Music]
we live in a secluded cove
the only option we have to get here is
by water there are no road accesses
the water is our highway
[Music]
everything that you see here
in our home is floating
we are tied to shore with lines we are
not anchored
we have our main living house
we have the dance floor
the lighthouse building
four greenhouses
as i started to grow the garden and make
it larger then we had to have more space
for that garden
everything's done with a hand saw and
hammer
no power tools i know every board and
nail by name
it's about 500 tons
a million pounds when i'm flowing
i've been building tree forts since i
was seven
and i said well dad i'm putting a tree
fort in the ocean do you ever get
seasick
no when i go to town i get landsank
the thing about living in clockwood
sound on the west coast of vancouver
island it's the richest biomass on earth
so the opportunity to fish for dinner is
big
and i just can get in my canoe and
paddle out in 10 minutes i can catch a
fish
but when it's windy and too too rough
out there i can lay on the couch and
fish out of the house
i was hoping to make a lot more money as
an artist
so subsistence living was our only
opportunity to have anything as artists
we could never buy real estate so we had
to make our own
it was a great opportunity to actually
move away from the city to see if we
could
prosper out here
now 24 years later we're still doing it
i can't imagine living any other way
i feel completely fulfilled
oh that's good
that's really nice
i'm working on it
[Music]
seven miles off estonia's west coast in
eastern europe lies the small island of
canoe a bucolic and serene place that
feels lost in time
home to just 400 people it functions
like one of the world's few matriarchal
societies
this is a place where women rule well
mostly everything hello welcome to
quinoa island
[Music]
my name is maria matas
i
lived almost all my life in this island
our lifestyle is different comparing the
lifestyle in the mainland many old
traditions still alive
one such tradition is that canoes men
spend months away at sea fishing for the
island
meanwhile canoes women are in charge of
leading the community and preserving its
way of life
men were always a long time away from
the island and some of the historical
reason why women become a very strong
very independent
kenyan culture is interesting because we
have still wear traditional costumes as
a everyday wearing she is making skirts
because she has five granddaughters
we have ancient folk songs still alive
and dances they have a lot of practical
skills how to
live all over the year here
yes life is more difficult here to
survive it's treasure for quinoa
islanders they all described ireland
like it's like a paradise it's the best
place in the world
[Music]
[Music]
the clothes the music
the dancing
all of it has been recognized by unesco
on its intangible cultural heritage list
the king of wedding songs and vedic
traditions are more than two thousand
years old so this is amazing why we are
in this unesco list
the same list acknowledges canoes women
as the custodians of their island's
heritage
i concern every day that our unique
culture can disappear
it's very valuable if those things still
exist and survive in the modern world
it's really
miracle
[Music]
okanoshima island is a short 12-minute
ferry ride from hiroshima region of
japan
while the sandy and palm line beaches
are perfect for holiday makers the
island draws crowds for a different
reason
rabbits
lots of them
and how they got there is a mystery
[Music]
between 1929 and 1945 the japanese army
secretly produced over 6 000 tons of
poison gas on okanoshima island some
believe the current rabbits are
descendants of those brought to the
island to test the gas but the current
director of the poison gas museum
insists these bunnies have nothing to do
with those from the world war ii era
so where do they come from
[Music]
[Music]
so those rabbits were released and with
no real predators they bred like
well
like rabbits
and yet another theory
okay
either way this new generation of feral
rabbits has the run of the land and
they're creating a new story separate
from the sordid past of okinoshima
island an island once known for death is
now known for possibly the cutest thing
ever
bunnies
[Music]
lake titicaca is home to movable
floating islands that were created by
humans
and where over 500 people still reside
today
living on not so solid ground isn't for
everyone but a small south american
tribe in peru known as uros have created
and maintained this unique way of life
the community is made up of roughly 70
human-made islands and one large central
island which is the hub for the tribe
they use dried reeds that grow along the
banks of the lake and shape them into
floating platforms and boats
these platforms can be moved from the
mainland if required which was
originally a defense strategy to escape
danger
[Music]
the reeds are interwoven densely to be
about 80 inches thick
large logs are attached through the
reeds and anchored to the river floor
over time the reeds tend to rot and so
they are replaced four times each year
the community is home to the new and old
world
the reeds are used as medicine and the
flower is drunk as tea however the solar
panels are used to help run some
electrical appliances and the central
island is home to a radio station
until the mid-80s the islands were
located further out in the lake and were
inaccessible by visitors however after a
devastating storm the tribe has moved
closer to land and started welcoming
tourists to experience their way of life
[Music]
you